Her low freak bitches.
This is what I want to say.
I want to see Nick Diaz versus Conor Mcgregor.
That's what I want to say.
I want to see that more than I want to see anything in life.
I wish I had,
so I want to say it more than I want to see the Aurora borealis more than I want
to go to the Keck observatory in Hawaii and revisit the Milky Way more than I
want to see any of those things.
I want to see Nick Diaz versus Conor Mcgregor.
Yeah,
Nick Diaz Kinda regretted how to cool his little walk around and wearing as he
got in.
It was awesome.
He was awesome.
He's a bad mother fucker.
Did with the way he walked around it would he got in the ring?
I didn't think he was going to get punched in the face as much as he did and we
still won,
but that was a cocky interest.
I was like,
oh,
he bought the first round,
knock out this mother fucker.
The way he just came in here.
Well,
I mean,
what he's trying to do is just like shake it off,
put an air out there.
But at the end of the day he's fighting Nate Diaz.
He's no one's getting know first round knock out.
This is getting crazy war.
He knew it and that he had to be conservative in that fight.
Energy was so crazy.
Oh my God.
It was insane.
It was so,
it was,
I was so nothing ever right.
It was so,
I'm so glad I went to see your lab.
Oh Man.
So he,
me too.
So I'm a as,
as I say,
I'm a casual fan so he's a couple of times where a kind of knocked him to the
ground,
kind of doesn't want to do ground game with him cause he was,
he was not into the ground.
Right.
He was,
he was,
he was telling me to come up where I would think normally for my lack net that
much,
you know,
intimate knowledge,
I would think once you knock somebody to the ground,
you try to go in with those hammer fists.
However,
if you do that with a guy like Nate Diaz,
he might not be hurt at all,
especially when you consider the fact that,
uh,
he Connor through a bunch of like really powerful left leg kicks and he had
fucked up Nate's right leg cause because of the fact they're both south paw,
what happens is like that back leg becomes the front leg,
the right leg is in front,
right?
And he just getting chewed up.
But this left power leg kicked up right from the beginning,
like over and over and over and over again.
When you,
when you get hit with a bunch of like really powerful leg kicks like that,
it makes it super difficult for you to move.
Right.
You know,
and then Conor just fought a smooth,
smart game plan.
You know,
he,
um,
it engaged from the outside where he,
his speed was an advantage and did some damage but didn't unload himself like he
did in the first fight.
In the first fight.
He did that too,
but any unloaded himself and Nate survived.
And when he survived,
Connor's gas tank was empty.
Right.
So this time Connor was way more conservative.
Let's see.
He would run away,
but he would run away.
No,
you could.
You could say it.
He would run away.
He ran away.
But when he was on a cane,
when get close to the KT over,
run it and make it more into the center it,
man,
it's okay.
You don't,
people are mad that he ran away
because it sucks.
Sometimes you take a break,
sometimes you take a break.
He knows the three moments in the round he's got,
he knows there's,
I mean,
I don't know when it was.
There was,
there was a couple moments in time where he totally turned away from him,
but then he engaged.
Yeah,
he did.
It wasn't like he was running the whole,
he was just,
when he found himself in a compromising position,
he would,
he would get out of it.
It's interesting.
It's an interesting thing to do it guys trying to kick your ass.
Like I'm going to go over here for a minute.
Yeah.
It's something funny about it.
You know,
seemed like a good move.
It's the right move.
When you,
when you don't feel like you can fight right now,
what do you want to do?
Stand in New Logo,
moon and don't get on the gin.
Bush,
John,
mom,
Jenny.
If you don't feel like you can breathe,
maybe you should move away and breathe.
Otherwise,
some dude could punch you in the body and you can go down.
It's like it's not a smart move to stand in there if you feel tired.
Yeah.